thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video find out more later on hey 42 here
the very best books and films really
make you think
the matrix had us wondering whether our
world might be a simulation
the lion king forced me to google
whether or not hakuna matata
really did mean no worries
it does in swahili
and jurassic park alerted us to the
possibility that we humans might one day
be able to bring the dinosaurs back from
extinction
this last idea got a lot of attention
earlier this year when rumors began to
circulate online that a certain elon
musk had developed a technology to
recreate jurassic park and this wasn't
just your standard internet smoke and
mirrors either the rumor was triggered
by a tweet written by max hodak
the man who co-founded noro technology
startup nora link with elon musk himself
we all know mr musk has his fingers and
lots of pies
but so far as anybody knew at the time
bringing the dinosaurs back from
extinction was one baked good he hadn't
penetrated with any of his many
appendages
so was there any truth to the rumor
sadly no there wasn't
the max hodak tweet was real but it
turns out he was just speculating about
humanity's growing technological
capabilities
rather than announcing some previously
top-secret nora link tech as it turns
out the whole bringing animals back from
extinction thing isn't quite as
far-fetched as you might think in fact
we've already done it not with dinosaurs
admittedly the animal in question was a
pyrenean ibex a kind of mountain goat
that was once abundant on the iberian
peninsula before it became extinct in
2003 scientists successfully cloned this
creature for a process called somatic
cell nuclear transfer
unfortunately the pyrenean ibex didn't
stay unextincted for very long
cloning is still an inexact science and
only one live ibex was born out of over
200 attempts
the baby only survived for a handful of
minutes before succumbing to a malformed
lung even so it was a huge milestone
for a brief time an animal that was once
fought gone forever
breathed again on planet earth
think of it as being a kind of non-evil
necromancy
only don't call the scientists involved
necromancers they don't like that
do you love travelling then you'll love
the fastest and easiest vpn surf shark
did you know surf shark helps you to
avoid price discrimination based on your
location so you can actually save money
on plane tickets and car rentals whilst
travelling surfshark runs on any device
anywhere and it's packed full of
features such as industry-leading
uncrackable encryption ip and dns leak
protection an internet kill switch of
your vpn drops out and 24 7 customer
support not forgetting it's easy to
install and you can run it on unlimited
devices on a single subscription
by using surfsharkvpn you can stay
anonymous and secure online personally i
use surfshock to watch netflix content
from other countries such as the us
that's usually blocked here in the uk
it's so easy all you have to do is
switch over your location settings and
there you have it access to all your
favorite programs by using code 42 you
will benefit from an 83 discount plus
three extra months for free all you have
to do is click the special link in the
description below don't miss out so if
we can bring back an ibex surely it's
only a matter of time before we're able
to resurrect the dinosaurs
with the inevitable consequence that we
humans are hunted close to extinction by
out-of-control herds of velociraptors
actually things aren't quite as simple
as that because as great as being
murdered by a flanking velociraptor
might sound in principle it turns out
that casting ray's dead on the dinosaurs
is going to be orders of magnitude
harder than it was for the pyrenean ibex
you see the reason we were able to bring
back the ibex is that it died out very
recently just over two decades ago in
the year 2000
scientists at the time already knew
cloning was possible dolly the sheep the
first mammal clone via somatic cell
nuclear transfer was born in
1996. so when it became clear that
pyrenean ibex was not long for this
world
tissue samples from the last surviving
female were taken and frozen
and
hidden within those cells was everything
we needed to make a brand new ibex
dna as you're probably aware the
dinosaurs met their maker some 66
million years ago there weren't any
scientists around at the time to take
any handy tissue samples meaning if we
want to get our hands on some dinosaur
dna for cloning
we're going to have to get creative the
obvious place to start is with fossils
but we could also have a go at finding
dinosaur blood in the stomachs of
ancient biting insects preserved in
amber like they did in jurassic park
but there's a major problem with both of
these approaches that wasn't fully
understood when the first jurassic park
film came out it turns out that dna is
an incredibly fragile molecule that
degrades relatively rapidly after its
owner dies
to put some numbers around that our
current best guess is that a dna
molecule loses around half the
information encoded within it every
521 years
meaning the older a dna sample is the
more damaged it's going to be thanks to
this gradual degradation if we go back
far enough around 6.8 million years
recoverable dna will essentially cease
to exist
lots of things have happened here on
earth in the last 6.8 million years
modern humans evolved
i ate breakfast more than 10 000 times
and piers morgan won the seven series of
celebrity apprentice in america
but none of these things involve
dinosaurs
well except maybe that last one i should
point out that a fair few scientists
have claimed to have found genuine
dinosaur dna fragments in recent years
which might blow this whole theory out
of the water but as of today all of
these findings are pretty controversial
and none are widely accepted by the
scientific community the oldest
confirmed dna fragments recovered and
sequenced came from a siberian woolly
mammoth that died 1.2 million years ago
well short of dino time so
yeah it's no exaggeration to say that
according to our best estimates there
may well be not a single molecule of
recoverable dinosaur dna in existence on
planet earth today
which isn't a great starting point for
cloning a dinosaur but hey if there's
one thing we humans should have learned
by now it's that our best guesses are
often pretty
just ask anyone alive before charles
darwin published on the origin of
species the problem is even if we're
wrong and tiny fragments of dinosaur dna
do exist out there somewhere
it doesn't really change much if
dinosaur genetic material has survived
it will have degraded to such a degree
that the most we'll ever find will be
tiny snippets of dna containing just a
handful of base pairs
to put that into context trx dna is
estimated to have contained more than 2
billion base pairs
and in order to reconstruct the entire
genome
we'd need to find
all of it
that simply isn't going to happen
if you're a proper jurassic park geek
you'll know that scientists from
overcame the problem of incomplete
dinosaur genomes by filling in the gaps
with dna sequences from other animals
frogs in the case of the films but the
reality is you can't fill in the gaps in
a dna sequence
unless you know where those gaps are
and you don't know where the gaps are if
you don't know what the whole sequence
is supposed to look like in the first
place
to put all of that very simply if we
can't find decent volumes of high
quality dinosaur dna
we just can't clone any dinosaurs
and we can't find dinosaur dna because
the dinosaurs have been extinct for 66
million years
or have they
actually
no
they haven't
as you're probably aware modern day
birds are descended from dinosaurs
in fact in a very literal sense birds
are dinosaurs
feathered ferropots if you want to get
technical on the face of it that might
not seem to help much either birds do
give us access to complete genome
sequences of genuine dinosaurs but only
of the species of dinosaur that still
exist today
and by that definition we don't want to
bring them back from extinction
still if birds evolved from ferropods a
group of dinosaurs that includes dino
a-listers like t-rex and the
velociraptor
then in theory their dna should be able
to tell us quite a lot about those
long-dead creatures
in fact if we were somehow able to
undo all the changes that have
accumulated in modern bird dna since the
time of the dinosaurs
it might just be possible to actually
make reverse engineered dinosaurs
now admittedly that might sound pretty
far-fetched and yeah
sorry it is we aren't going to be able
to pull a t-rex out of the bird dna hat
but that doesn't mean reverse evolving
birds is a total bust
in fact there are some pretty smart
people out there working on doing
exactly that right now
chief amongst them is a man called jack
horner you probably aren't familiar with
that name but he just so happens to be
the inspiration for alan grant the
paleontologist played by sam neal in the
jurassic park franchise
yeah he's kind of a big deal progress in
reverse evolution in the last decade or
so has actually been pretty remarkable
jack horner and other scientists like
him have already been able to identify
certain genes that appear to have been
instrumental in several key evolutionary
advancements that took place as birds
evolved from dinosaurs things like beak
formation for example and by inhibiting
the expression of those genes in chicken
embryos we've been able to make chickens
with dinosaur-like snouts instead of
beaks
weird progress is already being made in
identifying some of the genes involved
in wing and tail formation too
so
as mad as it may sound
it looks like it's only a matter of time
before we're able to make ourselves a
bunch of genuine dino chickens
but a dino chicken isn't really a
dinosaur or at least not one that ever
existed here on earth
it's just a chicken that's been
genetically engineered to have certain
dinosaur-like properties and even then
it's easy to forget that there's an
awful lot about the dinosaurs we still
don't know which means we don't have a
clear idea what dinosaur-like properties
actually are in the first place
and we're talking pretty fundamental
things here too like whether or not
dinosaurs were warm or cold-blooded all
of which means genetically engineering a
chicken is more of an interesting
science experiment than a genuine
attempt to resurrect long dead species
so whilst reverse evolution can teach us
a lot about evolution and gene
expression
it isn't exactly jurassic park and the
cold hard truth is that nothing ever
will be
for the reasons we've already talked
about and several others we haven't
we will almost certainly never be able
to bring the dinosaurs back from
extinction
but whilst the part of 10 year old me
just died inside
that doesn't mean we can't bring other
extinct species back plenty of animals
that died out in the last million years
or so
many of which sadly have us to thank for
their demise
could be perfect candidates for a spot
of good-natured necromancy
though there are still quite a few
hurdles to overcome before de-extinction
becomes d-rigger at the moment cloning
via somatic cell nuclear transfer
requires donor egg cells from living
animals to act as hosts for the genetic
information of the speries you want to
clone but if the egg cell itself comes
from a different species
by definition the resulting creature
isn't an entirely pure clone dolly the
sheep for example had the mitochondrial
dna of whichever sheep donated the egg
cell she grew out of there are other
challenges to overcome too when
scientists brought the pyrenean ibex
back from extinction the cloned embryo
was inserted into the womb of a
surrogate mother a domestic goat closely
related to the pyrenean ibex we'd have
to do something similar for every
species we want to bring back
but for extinct species with no
surviving close relatives in the animal
kingdom
we have nowhere to grow our cloned
embryos artificial wombs could provide
the solution but that's very much an
embryonic science i'm so sorry
still unlike finding dinosaur dna that
probably doesn't exist anymore
these are the kinds of challenges we
could conceivably overcome in the
relatively near future which means we
may well be able to bring some animals
back from extinction
sooner rather than later
likely candidates include the woolly
mammoth the phyluscene better known as
the tasmanian tiger and the passenger
pigeon not quite as exciting as a
rampaging t-rex i admit but on the plus
side you aren't very likely to be eaten
by a passenger pigeon
thanks for watching
do you really enjoy my content but you
literally can't be asked to use your
eyes
then you're in luck because you can now
listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast you'll
find a link to it in the description
below check it out today and give your
eyes a break you're welcome